plastische räte eines der eines der
renommiertesten krankenhäuser der welt
mit den besten experten der welt sagt ja
da wurde ein giftstoff identifiziert ja
er wurde vergiftet ist ein wahnsinnig
wichtiges signal
natürlich vor allem für die für die
vertrauten für die verwandten von
navalny die sich bestätigt darin sehen
können was auch muss man sagen von
anfang an wirklich offensichtlich war er
wie blenden gerade auch die tweets ein
einen der wichtigsten sätze vielleicht
auch in diesem dort geht es um die
klinischen befunde jetzt also gemacht
worden sind und natürlich auch noch mal
gesagt worden ist dass verschiedene
unabhängige labore das jetzt
sichergestellt oder festgestellt haben
wäre das in russland überhaupt möglich
gewesen ja es gibt in russland nichts
was so einen politischen fall unabhängig
beurteilen analysieren und kommunizieren
könnte und das dach ist auch ein sehr
wichtiger kluger schritt das hier
unabhängige labore so wie ich das
verstehe wo unabhängig voneinander
offenbar blutproben erhalten haben um
diesen giftstoff zu untersuchen weil man
muss ja auch wissen wie russland auf so
etwas gerne reagiert russland behauptet
da na ja dieses labor war nicht
unabhängig weil es von der
bundesregierung finanziert wird da kann
man dem ihr nicht glauben und dieser
diesen propaganda spins kommt man
natürlich zuvor indem man einfach das
breiter streut und mehrere labore
einsetzt das macht das das macht das
glaubwürdiger auch wenn kein normaler
mensch einfach so die glaubwürdigkeit
der charité anzweifeln würde aber wir
haben es hier mit dem kreml zu tun